[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
sortir de la dépendance au gaz russe
la guerre en ukraine a rappelé avec
gravité le risque de dépendance
énergétique de la france et de l'europe
le gaz russe représente en effet 20% de
la consommation française et 40 % de
celle de l'europe
depuis le printemps 2020 le prix du
marché du gaz a déjà été multiplié par
trois
il devrait croître encore compte tenu
des légitimes sanctions prises à
l'encontre de la russie mais aussi des
éventuelles mesures de rétorsion que
pourrait envisager cette dernière
dans ces conditions la commission des
affaires économiques présidée par sophie
primas plaide résolument pour cinq
mesures d'urgence
premièrement le principe du coût
marginal régissant le marché de
l'électricité qui vit dans les faits le
prix de l'électricité à celui du gaz
doit être révisée sans délai
sans cela la flambée du gaz fossile
russe se répercutera inévitablement sur
celle de notre électricité nucléaire
décarbonée
deuxièmement l'approvisionnement en gaz
doit être diversifiée
pour pallier la suspension du gazoduc
north stream 2 il faut accélérer la mise
en service de terminaux permettant
d'importer du gaz liquéfié et
reconstituer des stocks stratégiques
pour les prochains hivers
troisièmement la décarbonation du gaz
doit être poursuivie en substituant une
production nationale de biogaz aux
importations de gaz fossile russe
il faut réviser la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie en ce sens et
conforter les dispositifs de soutien
pour débloquer les projets d'injection
de biogaz en attente
quatrièmement le bouclier tarifaire doit
être consolidée
les tarifs réglementés de la vente de
gaz ne sont bloquées que jusqu'au 30
juin 2022 et ne couvre que 7,5 pour cent
de la consommation de gaz française
il faut donc recalibré ce bouclier
tarifaire à l'aune de la crise gazière
en offrant une solution globale et
pérenne à tous les consommateurs ménages
entreprises et collectivités
territoriales
enfin les textes européens en cours
doivent être ajustées
par exemple il faut conditionner
l'intégration du gaz bas carbone à la
taxonomie verte un critères de
provenance
comme le résume daniel grémillet
président du groupe d'études énergie au
sénat il y a donc urgence à agir
pour en savoir plus consultez le
communiqué de presse de la commission
des affaires économiques publiés le 28
février 2022
[Musique]